do all gamers think the same well today
we find out when they just said the
phrase it's just a game it's such a weak
mindset
I also fully free Jubilee uploaded this
video do all gamers think the same the
premise is that you have a bunch of
gamers and they go to the left or to the
right depending on how much they agree
on an issue regarding to gaming I'm a
gamer so let's freakin do this
I don't think gaming is anti-women
like no guy is saying oh you can't play
online today because you're a woman I
don't think it's anti that's because
she's never played with me it's a joke
but I think there's just a lot more Sam
Sam you don't understand you have it
really bad all right I'm joking by the
way these are not my real opinions I am
just making jokes
spectrum that's what all gamers are on
get it that's one thing gamers have in
common as a joke another joke why do I
keep making them I'm Ariana Gamboa I'm
19 years old and I play Halo
competitively it is my passion and the
girls can also game girls can also game
I play Halo compatibly also shows
runescape and overwatch nice well done
Jubilee are you really sure
oh god one misconception is how much
work people actually put in there's a
lot that goes into it a lot of people
you know how to negative stigmas playing
games do nothing with his life rather it
can be a quite a healthy outlet and
people really build in the future stop
again don't do that don't point at me
all right so here we go finally let's
play along okay
I like energy drinks you guys can play
along alright so left side is agreed
sorry right side is agree left side is
disagree I would probably put myself
here
because I drink energy drinks all the
freakin time check out G fuel
enter the code P D pipe back keep
jumping he's definitely gonna go for it
wait I'm sorry can can you give me a
second to think about this this is not a
tough question
God Oh guys I please maybe drink an
energy drink I'll help you figure it out
okay damn 50/50 I only like energy
drinks with alcohol and easy drink with
alcohol isn't that super unhealthy is
that really bad many people actually die
from that
I definitely acknowledge the health risk
that some energy drinks have but for me
I mean not if you're drinking G fuel no
health risks entered the code PewDiePie
I don't know if I can say that yes sure
I am sure anxious non-stop having to
play at the top of my game and it helps
out a lot
culture not colliding the definition
that I what it's like what's a woman I
needed a definition of that what's a
woman tell me right now
alright this will be interesting okay
left or right I agree or disagree we can
already see oh I don't know where I
would go I probably go somewhere here
just so so I can now I'll go here
because any time I see a girl play a
video game and they say they play Halo
competitively in reality I just imagine
that they're really just playing
runescape and overwatch so I don't
really believe it Oh everyone has that
experience when they're in a Gaming
Lobby and well probably us females
probably experience this more why she
said it
everyone everyone struggles with it good
redic did can have a definition of
everyone like what does that mean as
soon as we speak we get called fat we
get called all these ugly names it
happens to me all the time as soon as I
speak fat I get her point I get her
point
she plays runescape okay I understand it
happens the line and that is still
something I deal with today as I did
10-15 years ago it is definitely a
terrible thing to experience I have a
girlfriend that dreams though sorry I
feel like I've gotten more open mind not
gonna lie I needed I need a definition
of what a girlfriend is I need about it
and understanding and I can definitely
understand those it's a funny night
females have to go through it's pretty
tough from people just saying dumb
or saying you're bad saying you
shouldn't compete or I think that's a
fair thing you don't really notice how
much girls get the same kind of dumb
jokes over and over it's like oh why do
you care but it's like it's so run to
the ground a lot of that people say to
girls online that it's just like it just
stopped being funny years ago basically
hear those things too but they don't
hear it because they're men you're right
right right they hear it because of
whatever like the internet wants to hate
on some manager
I disagree though cuz I think in general
people are much harsher on men because
oh it's like oh you can take it I'm a
competitor like I don't care about what
my gender is
what how much I weigh I don't care about
any of that like if I'm good enough like
that I'm good enough I just don't really
believe in that I think that's a fair
argument too and it's like you don't
want to be put in a box just because
people say oh well it's tough for you
that doesn't mean that you want to be in
that and acknowledge that in a way it's
like how do we fix these issues well
maybe just don't bring it up all the
time I don't know no guy is saying yeah
you cannot get on your computer because
you're a woman like no guy is saying
like she's like no I agree with that and
like I do agree that the skills speaks
for itself I agree with the skills
speaks for itself also disagrees with
the whole argument what the hell anyone
can typically play any game they want
and become good the environment makes it
so that it's much harder to succeed as a
woman than it is as a man there's no
doubt that the experience will be
different oh yeah this is different but
I don't think gaming is anti-women
I don't know I don't think it's anti
women but I don't think that way that
way then what are you doing over there I
think there there's just a lot more they
have to deal with um so like back then
you know arcades in the first like home
consoles girls and video games just
weren't a thing you know it was like a
boys only Club anytime a girl was like
interested video games guys would be
like oh no just go play make over go
back to the kitchen or something about
what the hell no sounds like you did
that you did that if any in my
experience whenever girls wonder place
like wait yeah hell yeah no please come
join the hell don't project your ideas
don't project your misogynistic history
and upper compensate for it by
government over there gaming culture has
advanced right and it's become more
accessible and diverse unfortunately
there's still you know some people out
there that still treat it like it's the
nineties
oh-oh-oh
someone agreed Oh take your because
there's proof
Wow I just want to like kind of not be
the odd one out the only reason I want
to say a little bit here is because
anyone remembers Columbine like they
were inspired by video games but like
it's just all mental health at the end
of the day I just think anyone who who
has those kinds of issues is gonna find
that inspiration from any kind of medium
including movies including games
including books that's why I'm saying we
need to censor all of it all media it's
not kind of going against the argument
though you're basically saying that all
of these things are encouraging it it's
kind of disingenuous to say that video
games doesn't and at least some way
encourage it hear me out hear me out I
finish thought because any medium will
inspire you in a way doesn't mean it
encourages it I think that key word is
encourage inspire it could inspire
violence I would say I just think it's
disingenuous to say that because we all
know they do these things that you can't
argue against that but I think the
argument that putting video games in a
specific box saying okay well it's their
fault
that's completely pointless and doesn't
solve any issue whatsoever
does that make sense I don't think there
would be such controversial topics Jesus
Christ there's so many of us that play
video games that don't have those kind
of thoughts how would it it's like your
site it's just a scapegoat
what oh okay good for traditional sports
you have to push your body to such
lengths to be able to do those physical
feats to be them yes whatever I just
don't think that it's as hard I agree
I'm usually like sitting on my computer
for almost 10 to 12 hours a day that's
physically demanding alright I'm not
doing anything near and NFL NBA players
do anything I don't play basketball but
I don't think that they're working on
like frames-per-second kinds of levels
of reaction and speed yeah in basketball
players they will never understand the
frames per second he strongly agrees
then you know not all sports are as
intensive as like football and like
soccer and you probably all thinking
basketball for me yeah what are you
talking about right bio chefs
it's a sport too and that's equally
physically demanding imagine a pro Matta
and video game player meeting them up
with a real football player be like yeah
we're pretty much the same we're pretty
much we pretty much put out the same
amount of physical work I met a lot of
people that are professional eSport and
I know it's highly demanding but I don't
think physically it's that it's the same
thing because it's like it's the
mainstream stuff you know because
there's also but there's also golf
there's also arts in bowling darts
almost a question competitive gaming is
just demanding as a physical sport a
physical sport when people say physical
sport they generally not talking about
bowling are they or darts trash talk
it's part of the fun
[Music]
damn it's hella fun it's competition you
know you trying to get everyone riled up
you turned out to throw everyone off
their game he's waiting for this one
yeah you know once we will start taking
like life problems and wait and try to
like find stuff up on you that's where
it gets petty and it's childish but um
trash-talking is super fun I do it a lot
on stream you know I'd yeah I mean I
love I love trash-talking people it's so
fun I never seen people bond so much of
our topic Jesus Christ Chuck you know
brings people together
I only say it on the mic because then
you can tell like you can understand my
tone is women calling us virgins all the
time it's not fair it's or not being a
woman also virgin family's skeptical
about career okay let's see their varied
them I'll start wait I don't understand
why does it say oh it's the Instagram
poll oh okay I was wondering why that
was different all the time damn so this
is kind of like what you guys would say
I mean my parents did a very similar
thing and after I graduated high school
I asked for a chance I was like hey
could I have just a year I want to
really see if I can make this work you
know I want to pursue - pretty fair he
asked your parents won the tournament
the course shot of him yeah if this was
three years ago I'd say I'd be over
there saying baby they'd be skeptical
dead I don't know but my dad's always
been supportive of me and I'm thankful
for that they understand it when they
see the money yeah you have to make
money for people to realize it's
actually a career yeah you sure well
that's the definition of the career
it's so fun judging people that are just
throwing away sentence that's not
thinking about it and then I can go what
a bunch of idiots I've never said
anything stupid in my life
YouTube is great to be fair I had the
same struggle by the way like my parents
when I talked about youth it was like no
no you're not doing this to be fair it
wasn't even a thing then that's right
I helped out gamers now when kids go and
say
but parents will be like now no even
more you're welcome oh great
actually I'll probably put disagree
because generally my gaming videos don't
do that well anymore so yes probably
strongly disagree so it depends on what
you guys to find us good living god this
guy can you stop being contrarian in
every point depends on what you guys to
find us good living I live in Silicon
Valley in the Bay Area the highest cost
of living ever this competitive gaming
career I have is it's a side hustle but
then move it somewhere else I'm poor
it's not a good job because I live in
expensive area what if I just did any
one of those by itself I would not make
it I used to live in a trailer with my
dad in Ohio so I understand the struggle
you know I used to sleep on the mattress
on a floor
you know gaming I started streaming I
started you know getting a lot of
attention in tournaments I was making a
lot of money there I mean now I live in
like in the really nice part of
California like rent free with my
girlfriend and there's a lot of money to
be made in gaming whether it's streaming
YouTube tournaments sponsorships the
World Cup that was like 30 million like
there's just the reason why I'm not on
stream strongly agree is because it's so
unreliable and inconsistent in my
opinion which is something that's pretty
fair ya know if we're gonna place topic
i'm i agree with Ariana comment payouts
can take months i i'd say i make a
really good living i think that
fortnight has given me a lot of
opportunities I mean the viewership and
the tournament prize winnings alone is
ridiculous I mean even for me I've
always just looked at YouTube like oh
yeah it's pretty on a reliable job
I probably shouldn't take it seriously
[Music]
we guess all of them because they only
play video games all day big surprise
like sure and we just have the time of
our life I just met them online through
gaming or at a tournament I agree with
you guys
I mean gaming has led me to a bunch of
events like twitchcon all these things
even this where I meet people and that's
built those hey remember when gaming
wasn't cool I remember okay
I brought my D Estes class and people
were like oh that's a cute little
console while you played games I went to
real struggle so you don't understand
how times have changed huh have times
have changed
you're welcome gamers I walked so you
could run why am i complaining well this
was interesting do all pro gamers think
the same OS pro gamers I don't even
think about that guess I can yeah I'm a
pro gamer I make a living out of it it's
my career so that's the definition thank
you guys for watching this video if you
enjoyed smash like sixty eight percent
of you aren't subscribed what the heck
subscribe right now and I see you guys
tomorrow and hopefully there will be
some meaningful content coming out at
some point
bye bye hey door hey hey